i want to jump to this story here and
give a shout out to the man the myth the
legend alex jones because uh
he was right about epstein if you're
listening to this you are the resistance
that's right he was uh he was right
about epstein i remember when uh when
the episode story broke joe rogan was
like dude alex jones was right yeah and
it's it's like it's crazy because alex
has gone on joe's show and said really
crazy stuff
chimeras 5g towers whatever
interdimensional beings and then he says
some of these other stories like the
epstein thing and you're like people
don't want to believe it and it turns
out to be true we got the story from
bloomberg being thrown off social media
was supposed to end alex jones's career
it made him even richer
i think this is an important story for
one they admit or at least they're
asserting they wanted jones it was
supposed to it is
it was supposed to
stop the spread of violence sorry that's
right they just admitted they just
straight up admit we were trying to end
his career they said initially it was
because he was promoting violence and
they had to stop it for the safety now
it's it was supposed to end his career
now you've got in the in the court case
against them you had the the lawyer uh
for the families say
don't just
punish him destroy his platform and make
sure he can't rebuild it
but i think this is a big story they
claim that alex jones is worth a lot of
money alex jones has commented to me on
the story saying that he does not in
fact have this much money he is not
making this money this much money
they're bankrupt and he's broke
look i know he said that but i kind of
find it hard to believe that someone
who's had such a powerful media empire
would not have saved up money somewhere
set up trusts with his family or
something so maybe personally yes he is
broke but a lot of a lot of that wealth
probably transferred out through various
trusts or other other other ways to you
know family members there was a story in
the new york post that he transferred a
portion of property to his wife or
something i don't know the fact is this
story is a white pill
the fact that they are so desperate to
stop alex jones and they can't yeah it
shows that
well alex despite all of the things
they've thrown at him and and the damage
they have caused to his business he's
persisted he survived and he's been
effective the reason they're going after
him is because he's one of the most
effective supporters of trump or was
and that he's influential
they saw i think at the same time
the white pill that they i think the fbi
going after trump that doesn't it makes
me a little bit pessimistic in terms of
civil war take a drink everybody but it
makes me actually optimistic in terms of
the upcoming elections they are so
panicked about
the influence of people like jones the
influence of people like trump that
they're desperately pulling moves like
this it's a whack-a-mole they've been
freaked out since 2007 when they
realized that an internet video blogger
on youtube could rally 500 000 people to
vote for whoever they want uh the cnn
got involved in 2007 we're like we're
gonna do the cnn youtube debates all
right kids all you super influential new
famous young people that are way more
powerful than we are let's create an
authority so we can kind of
make a semblance of controlling you and
so they did these lame-ass youtube
debates with cnn where they like
wouldn't i tried to ask questions about
the federal reserve and they like just
would ignore that of course
we talk about obama's favorite foods and
things like that
they're in complete
hanging by a thread the global financial
market i didn't know what globalists
were a liberal international economy
yeah that's it the lie i love it but i
remember back in the day like i said
back in the day but 10 years ago
obama did the reddit ama they asked me
anything it was like a big deal but he
only answered like what 10 questions and
they were very stocked like
what would you do with tech with
healthcare
we're going to give more of that we like
it what started changing is that i think
people are sick of the obvious lies
remember deepwater horizon
south park may have made a joke about
how the uh the bp guy goes on tv goes
we're so happy we're so sorry we're
sorry sorry when when that happens does
any reasonable person believe they're
going to tell the truth does any sane
person think that gensake or uh you know
jean-pierre are gonna come out and just
be like totally honest with the american
people and for that matter spicer or uh
you know sarah sanders for instance i
don't expect any of them to come out and
just blatantly tell me the truth about
what's going on not a republican not a
democrat not not trump's people there's
there's obvious legitimate reasons why
they can't tell you the truth for good
or bad
right we can't leak secrets if we have
plans we need to compartmentalize and
make sure our plans are you know if we
wanted something good we can't just go
out and explain exactly what we're doing
if i'm for instance going to be suing
some some organization
and i think it's a really good thing and
it needs to happen well coming out and
explaining in detail what i'm doing just
helps them and stops me from doing it so
for obvious reasons you're just not
getting the truth but what happens is
with people like alex jones
they feel authenticity and that was a
big shift whether jones was right or
wrong
you you the dude believes what he's
saying oh he's right a lot of times
he was talking about the globalists in
like 2005 and six i was like okay i
think he's being a little hyperbolic
he's being vague what the heck is he
even talking about but now i find out
that there's like
multinational corporations where they
have their headquarters in one country
but all their activity or a bulk of
their activities in another country
they're basically tax evading uh and
that's a huge i mean that's what he's
talking about he's talking about yellow
but he's talking about like world
economic forum crap remember uh i don't
know if you guys have been watching or
listening to alex jones for a long time
by chance
i don't know but i remember so i've been
on the internet my whole life
i remember the loose change virality
moment where people were burning loose
change in element of discs and like
sharing them around with everybody well
so um when i was in college i remember
that yeah the ron paul was like yeah
like the loose change guys would be
around yeah i told this to alex jones uh
the first time he came on the show i was
like i remember when you were ragging on
real id when you are like
they're going to be federalizing ids
this is what it means and he was raising
alarm bells about it and the potential
problems and what happens is we're frogs
in a pot the pot is boiling and we don't
realize how much has really changed but
i remember now a few years ago i go to
the airport and there's all the signs
everywhere get your real id update your
ids otherwise you're not compliant so he
was right about it and he said it would
do a bunch of things that it does
because he was reading the news and
reporting it accurately now we're in it
real id is here and nobody cares
everyone says like oh i got my id my id
updated whatever so he he talks about
the the incrementalization one small
grain of sand at a time and before you
realize that your whole world is
different well just think about this you
go to the store at walmart or wherever
you make some purchases on your credit
card all that data is there you go
online again on walmart and you look and
you say here's all the things you've
been buying do you want any more of
those
when the fbi wants data on you
they just send a letter to a t or to
walmart or to chase bank and they
request that data yep
and they have your whole life right
there your credit cards your purchases
where you were at apparently uh the
phone companies have been giving
people's text messages
to uh to like the january 6 committee
and stuff like that well this came up
also with ring camera
that a lot of the police department so
the the issue that came up was that
police departments ice other agencies
were
able to access ring without the
permission of
the but like derek saying just going to
the company directly and of course the
companies are saying hey we're we're
trying to prevent crimes what if there's
a
you know a child grabbing incident and
we caught it on bring camera you know
would you want to notify the authorities
right away but then the question and you
could say well yeah i mean i think
there's some utility to that obviously
but then the question of course becomes
how much are they watching or do they
know when you come in and out of your
home do they know who's coming in and
out of your home well that's metadata so
yes yeah that's all of it the crazy
thing about metadata and this is i think
it's been a while but i'm pretty sure
brett kavanaugh ruled in favor of the
government's ability to use metadata as
not as a violation of the fourth
amendment but i could be wrong about
that it's been a while since i was doing
research in that regard but the thing
about metadata is the argument is when
you walk outside your house anyone can
see you do it right so that's not a
right you have no expectation of privacy
if the police are sitting in public and
they watch you leave your home they now
know you left your home well that's too
bad the argument was that with metadata
when you visit websites
you're not hiding yourself you're not
there's no there's no expectation of
privacy when your computer sends a
request out anyone who wants can see it
the problem is
with metadata it's not just about
watching you leave your house we watch
your house we can guess where you're
going is it going to work what time is
it i don't know it's not going to work
maybe he's going to get food where is he
going to go i don't know with metadata
they can tell when you're gonna poop and
i'm not i'm not kidding
there was an article about how facebook
accurately predicts when people have to
make movements as it were because they
have all this metadata they know when
you put your phone down they know when
you're walking they know when you're
likely eating they can calculate all
this stuff and now the government can
easily get access to all of that the one
that i saw that was very similar to that
was um pregnancies that they could base
they could base based on your google
searches basically you know you're
saying i'm telling you know i have these
symptoms what's going on and the case
study that i remember reading was a girl
had gotten some ads in the mail for you
know like folic acid and basic pregnancy
stuff from coupons from the local target
because she was a frequent shopper there
they knew she was pregnant before she
did and the dad is the one who saw it
and said right what yeah and he called
why are you sending my daughter and they
were like oh it was right
right it was like an algorithm that i
remember she didn't know she was
pregnant but she was buying things yes
that they just knew
and so this was the pattern that led you
to big
big brother knows when you'll poop
before you do you know what concerns me
is we're talking about the fourth
amendment rights and is it a violation
of fourth of memorized but i think it's
so far beyond american government at
this point that when we complain about
what the american government the united
states american government is doing it's
kind of like just complaining about what
one of lieutenants is doing because
everyone all these governments have the
ability to scrape your metadata it
doesn't matter they don't have ccp
doesn't have a fourth amendment to
violate they just do whatever they want
so reality it is harder in a certain
sense for the ccp to get access to our
data than the us government because the
us government has authority over these
organizations they just call it barrick
swallow oil they just buy it yeah so the
ccp through any one of the companies
they control can just buy the data
and then they know just i want it's part
of the contract it gives them access to
it and that's what we've seen in some of
our investigations not only that but
let's talk about 23andme and how much
that is getting sourced by china
so i'll say i'll tell you uh why is it
why do you guys think 23andme is that
cheap
come on they're selling they're selling
all that stuff i was good i was i was at
a party and i'll keep the story as vague
as possible and i was talking to someone
about um wait tim you promised me you
would never
i was talking to somebody about covet
testing and i said something like you
know the the problem with the mass
testing is the concern that china is
going to get access to this this dna
information and then someone else
overheard
you know basically was like oh it's
conspiracy it's fake news
you know you can't go around saying
these things when people here pay
attention to the news and knows what's
going on you're lying blah blah i just
took my phone i pulled up the npr
article that says
china is getting access to data through
and they were like uh well i'm like dude
like i do this for a living right
i'm not making these stories up i'm
reading the news and that's that's
that's a lot for uh i would say the same
is true for alex jones
i think the issue with alex though is
that
he stretches things a little too far and
what i mean by that is atrazine was the
big story uh interfering with the
endocrine systems of frogs and then he
yells it's turning the frogs that was a
big problem they were turning them they
were making them hermaphroditic meaning
the
sex organs of the male and the female
they weren't gay and he said that they
were turning them gay like the problem
with alex and is that over time is that
he's also he leans into the
entertainment the jokester
but bad for you here's okay but explain
this to me why does the rachel maddow
standard not apply to alex jones
oh right why is it that when you when i
forget who it was but they were suing
rachel maddow over this and they and
then she came in and said well this is
an opinion show everything everything i
say is my opinion and the judge rules
okay well then it's all covered well for
alex i don't even care about legality
stuff that's not what i meant when i was
saying the problem i just i'm concerned
like why why he's looked at as ridiculed
by as he has been by society because he
does both the jokes and the news
so this one thing that happened when he
was being sued i think is that
he claimed he was acting and then the
left came out and they were alive
and he was like no he does commercials
there's a commercial where he rips his
shirt off and then scott and then flies
through the ceiling of his building the
commercial right yeah he actually
turned red come on i i do want to shout
out yeah that that ad where he's like a
redder you know the ones like before and
after
yeah i don't know
was
but
it was hilarious either way my favorite
one it was the doctor i forget who it
was but he he takes the supermale
vitality and goes i will now activate my
muscles by doing push-ups
and then he just like tears his shirt
off and starts doing push-ups and he
comes up and he's got he's turned into
like a werewolf
and then he says he's acting and then
yeah you know it's funny when i see it i
see
i talk to regular people or i see
facebook posts from a lot of these
lefties they don't know anything about
the guy they don't know they don't know
they they sit there blindly believing
the lies it's it's it's remarkable to me
that after all of the lies these people
still don't wake up and it's gotta be
willful well it's a double standard all
the time we see with the media you know
one standard for liberals another
standard for conservatives but you know
this this issue that you're touching on
i think you know strikes home to a lot
of our listeners
yeah well and and when i bring up rachel
maddow it's it's not necessarily to to
point out that it's double standard in
terms of the way society presents them
but now you've got a situation in the
united states where you're creating and
and derek you talk about this all the
time this two-tiered system of justice
where one
one standard can apply to alex jones and
you can ruin him and take away his
entire career because he got a story
wrong but rachel maddow is perfectly
fine to say whatever she wants because
it's her opinion we need parallel
economies so shout out to dan van gino's
parallel
yeah shout out to rumble and shout out
to public square public square love it
if you guys haven't downloaded public
square
yeah public square is uh an app that
shows you all the businesses that that
believe in your values and all that
stuff so we i'm thinking about i agree
with you on video the peril the
parallelity that we do need like 2007
internet video you could tell that the
young video bloggers were taking control
of society
what does the government the federal
government have that we don't like if we
were to create like just the army keep
they have the army they have like the
tax
code system 87 000 armed irs agents who
are trained to kill poor people so it's
all like military it's all like guns and
enforcement they control like the
enforcers they have the stick and that's
they is just like what the executive
branch in congress basically you don't
want to give that i don't want to give
that stuff to the populace no it's not
just the executive branch in congress
that's that's the problem though is it's
supposed to be the executive branch in
congress backstop by the judiciary but
the problem with all of this is that you
have an administrative state that has
grown and become the fourth branch of
government that's who liz cheney is
campaigning for that's your msnbc your
cnn plug-in right there they're tied
into academia they're tied into the
entire education system they're tied
into the defense industrial complex this
is that fourth branch of government that
was never supposed to be do you think
it's that we need it to no exist within
this global system of like totalitarian
governments vying for control absolutely
not then do you think it's like i mean
we need we you need a military right you
need a military industry you need
industry to keep up with that military
sure but the the power should always be
with the representatives and you have a
congress that's completely abrogated
that because most congressmen or a lot
of them i'm not going to say all of them
but they would rather go raise money and
hang out on the golf course and then do
whatever the lobbyist wants it's the
rule-making and enforcement mechanisms
of of
epa or department of education with new
rules and executive orders on lots of
different issues that affect our our
kids going to school it's a doj and fbi
being immune from real oversight and
control
by the executive branch the president
whether it was president trump or
whether it's
joe biden who says i don't know what's
going on no one's talked to me thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and we'll
see you all there
you